there was a set script at the top of
every filming day but
each day we'd sort of branch outside of
it some of the sharpest looking scenes
were ideas that came in the moment and
improv led to more than one iconic line
we've got 15 of our favorite improvised
thor scenes and the stories behind them
coming your way every day was
improvised number one
just wait to be caught off guard chris
pratt taika waititi and chris hemsworth
all in one room together it was an
improvaganza however hemsworth had
forgotten just how good pratt was when
it came to working off the cuff
explaining the guy is wildly impressive
with the spontaneity and the humor and
the things he comes up with it's both
funny inspiring and intimidating
the film is packed with improv but it
really was pratt who shined in
hemsworth's eyes
not me
what just listening number two show up a
guest leave a writer that was
essentially what happened for a kid from
the make-a-wish foundation who visited
the thor ragnarok set and wound up
contributing one of the best lines to
the movie
we know each other he's a friend from
work
it works so well it seems like that was
part of the og script or something
hemsworth would have come up with
himself but the idea came from the young
guest on set who hemsworth chatted with
between takes the genius suggestion that
hulk and thor were connected through
work made the moment in that arena so
much better loki look who it is
luckily hemsworth knew how great an idea
it was and was all for it
number three you know what scene we're
talking about
hey let's do get help
what get help two brothers improvise and
make movie magic while this bit was all
an old game for the bros it originally
came from the mind of chris hemsworth
get help was uh
genuinely improvised not too different
from what we actually see play out in
the scene they didn't have to act much
since loki was reluctant throughout
thor's convincing argument anyway being
able to go this wild with an improv was
thanks to taika waititi encouraging the
cast to just go nuts with the script and
bring all they could to it resulting in
multiple takes of most scenes
oh classic oh i still hate it it's too
many not for me it's not
number four
they've had an intense past while thor
is ready to go when it comes time to
talk about his brother throwing him
under the bus with the most creative of
insults the snake story really took the
improv cake filming this hilarious scene
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes the
performance is shockingly convincing
reminding us just how well suited to
play thor hemsworth is to pick up the
snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and he was like yeah
it's me and he stabbed me
the snake story actually existed in a
few different forms and multiple were
filmed but ultimately when they had all
the footage on the cutting room floor
this version stuck out as the best way
to go oh and by the way all those
versions hemsworth improvised
they were super varied one with a pretty
intense focus on turkish rugs
number five if he wins you'll know it
even if he doesn't exactly win jeff
goldblum was really reveling in getting
to go off the handle whipping out any
dialogue he could think of to punch up
the scene with director ytt at the helm
he would say well keep the camera
rolling because i got 23 other ideas and
he would go say say this say that the
post-credit scene with the grand master
was the perfect end to a romp of a film
yay us
and seeing how on a roll he was to begin
with we can't even imagine how many
comedy gems wound up being cut for the
sake of length in the end me too because
i've been a a big part of it can't have
a revolution without somebody overthrow
number six
we gotta talk about these tools well
taika ytt and chris hemsworth sure did
even when they weren't actually supposed
to
unique was made from this
special metal from the heart of a dying
style yeah this casual weapons chatting
scene was really only supposed to be a
single line but get these two in a room
and well when i spun it really really
fast it gave me the ability to fly you
wrote a hammer
no i didn't ride down
this magic is what you get
pulled me off oh my god emma pulled you
off the ground would pull me off the
ground up with tyka being both in front
of and behind the camera the improv in
those scenes he performed in could go a
little overboard and thus the rant from
thor was born while hemsworth was the
one responsible for the dialogue he
credits the art department for having
created so many special and unique
looking weapons it's a nice way of
putting it
number seven ain't no move quite like a
signature move it wasn't just hemsworth
who had all the fun on set tom
hiddleston brought some of his own charm
purely by accident luckily it resulted
in a gem of a moment basically i think i
finished my moves before idris and he
was still rolling and i didn't want to
just be standing there like a lemon not
doing anything interesting so i just
flipped the knives and caught them by
chance this search for new choreo led to
a move that would appear in the loki
series on disney plus after the fact as
well hiddleston had to give credit where
it was due though tycho set him up for
success
his
freedom at work and his invention is an
amazing thing to behold number eight who
doesn't love a good hand gesture
grandmaster is here and he knows his
hand gestures
and doesn't everyone watch this
dial it down
that's dial it down why did this go on
so long well that was thanks to tyka he
would say he could keep the camera
rolling it was news to the grand master
that these various hand gestures aren't
clearly universal but we love seeing him
try to explain it here's i'd like
dessert
this improvised moment was so good it
nearly did make the cut but in the end
it clearly would have run too long if
they wanted to keep the gag running it's
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen number nine who wants more korg we
want more korg if you were to read the
original thor ragnarok script first of
all you'd read only bits of what
actually made the movie but one thing in
particular would stand out there was
originally way less korg with taika
running the ship and playing that part
the 140 tooth scrapper
it was inevitable that improv would take
them away to the korg show he loves to
um
to kind of play with the scene on the
day number ten don't dig the vibes then
change them both chris hemsworth and
tycho ytt were feeling a certain way
about thor in hemsworth's own words i'm
sick of myself and in taika's
i'm sick of you too
so they did something about it we
basically decided just to kind of
reinvent the character in the world and
with the quest to spice the character up
they quickly decided to give his hair a
chop and it wasn't just for character
reasons
partly due to i didn't want to spend two
hours in hair and makeup putting a wig
on now that's fair and clever on
hemsworth's part number 11. where else
would you put a hammer what else is
there to do but joke between takes
really hemsworth was doing his thor
thing and then decided it would be funny
to hang the hammer up on a coat hook it
was funny to hemsworth and everyone else
so of course they had to include it in
the movie number 12 you don't want to
get on his bad side anthony hopkins
commands the screen for a reason in his
portrayal as odin but who knew some of
his best performance moments came
straight from the actor himself the
speech that sees him tearing into thor
was majorly brought to life by the actor
himself you are a vain
greedy
cool boy and that vicious snarl at loki
just the cherry on top of an incredibly
strong improv from the anthony hopkins
number 13.
or if you're thor it's another just
drink i like it i know it's great right
no though that mug smash from thor in
the first of the thor films was
unexpected and totally jarring for
everyone on set
no one was anticipating that chaos with
100 genuine reactions like that well
they were too good not to use so this
wild but perfect moment made the movie
you couldn't script a better scene
once kevin feige saw the result he was a
fan for life and insisted the moment be
included
number 14
if you know you know sure there was a
fight happening in wakanda but thor and
cap had some other things on their mind
chris hemsworth and evans were on set
together prepping to film their reunion
on the battlefield and as they were
scheming what they could bring into the
scene it occurred to them that they just
had to talk to each other about how
different they were looking your haircut
noticed you've copied my beard
helmsworth explained it's like great are
you unwell
what's happened
take after take was done workshopping
the moment until they struck gold and as
a bonus we got a whole lot of extra
blooper reel footage
evans was a bit off but i don't think
much
number 15
nothing beats wraps with pals this scene
was so important the team actually came
back to set after they'd already wrapped
just to film it that's commitment to the
craft if it weren't for rdj mentioning
it off the cuff after nearly losing his
life have you ever tried shawarma
there's a shawarma joint about two
blocks from here i don't know what it is
but i want to try it then we'd never
have gotten this iconic moment
this one was definitely worth getting
back to the set for they came they
improvised they laughed they conquered
all the collaboration from these actors
becomes evident seeing their brilliantly
spontaneous and authentic interactions
with each other they really are the
characters and vice versa which
improvised scene was your favorite